and now five years of people prematurely
declaring the end of Obamacare today
after all the votes have been tallied
health insurance reform becomes law in
the United States of America but just
seven minutes later the ink
barely dry Republicans launched a
counter-attack I'm confident that the
court is going to declare the new health
care reform law unconstitutional we have
the Supreme Court about to look at it
Andreea some have said that this is
maybe the beginning of the end
of Obamacare it is that could happen
next week in the United States Congress
and we can put an end to Obamacare
Michele Bachmann's campaign promised to
quote end Obamacare well Obamacare still
stand 24 hours from now Obamacare will
end sure sounds like the beginning of
the end for Obamacare but we really want
to see at the end of Obamacare we're
going to put an end to Obamacare was
this the beginning of the end for the
Affordable Care Act Tuesday two days ago
was the beginning of the end for
Obamacare is this the beginning of the
end for Obamacare
the hearing today at the Supreme Court
could lead to the collapse of Obamacare
could spell the end of Obamacare what
will happen is at the end of Obamacare
after multiple challenges to this law
before the Supreme Court the Affordable
Care Act is here to stay is the fight
against Obamacare for Republicans over
now my short answer would be no